rosabeth moss kanter I have a chair
professorship at harvard business school
in Ohio I don't think where I'm from has
shaped me much at all although I used to
call it middle America heights because I
grew up at a time when the suburbs were
flourishing but I was very urban
oriented I remember spending a great
deal of time in the city I was always
interested in larger problems of the
world and even though I adored my family
I couldn't wait to get out and be part
of the wider world as a young person I
can't say that very many people
influenced me at all I seem to chart my
own course I started writing plays when
I was very little I remember writing a
play when I was in kindergarten and I
joked recently where we for a
performance in which we had to write
very funny bios that I wrote my first
play at age six and have been trying to
put words and other people's mouths
since well I what I thought I'd be doing
professionally changed dramatically
through the years although it's also
remained remarkably similar that is I
thought I would be a professional I
thought I would advise important leaders
in the world i thought i would write but
the ways in which i thought i would do
it have changed i was very interested in
science when i was young but somehow I
got encouraged out of science and toward
the humanities and by the time i was in
college i was interested in the
humanities but american civilization and
I then discovered that there was a way
to combine science and humanities
through the social sciences and those
were filled I didn't know much about and
so I got a PhD I realized that you had
to do that to be taken seriously and I
began that combination of activities so
in some ways I've done the same thing my
entire life I have researched and
written about important problems and
important issues I have advised the
heads of major organizations I have
been an entrepreneur served on civic and
nonprofit and national and even
international boards and so what I've
done hasn't changed but the particular
topics have changed
you